[Music]
so say this up top I'm a big big movie
guy movie fans in the house you guys
like those multi-million dollar mask
pieces of entertainment me to love
actors we all love actors but I was I
was thinking about actors if you really
look at what an actor does their job is
kind of nuts I've ever thought about
that it's a little bit crazy I've done a
little bit of acting myself but I don't
consider myself like a real actor I'm
talking about real actors and I've been
in scenes with real actors and we're
waiting to get started in front of the
cameras they can come on and be real
casual just like oh yo yo go myself a
mini woody it's a little camper it's a
little camper just big enough for me and
the wife it's gonna be great
it's not too big a little Kitsch got a
little kitchen in the mini Winnie I love
it it's really really great I look
really excited I think we're gonna tour
the Dakotas that could Dakotas it's
gonna be great and it'll be like action
and who'll be like excuse me one second
yeah it's really it's a good size
there's enough it's enough of the
vehicle for me that's crazy but because
it's an actor we love it it's okay if
somebody in your office could start fake
crying on a dime pretending they care
about something and totally look like
they care about it when they don't just
like Dan what's wrong somebody did
somebody die not just my thing it's my
special talent you'd be like damn that
guy's a sociopath call the cops but when
it's Clooney we can't wait to shower
that sociopath with cash awards and
their finest legal women but I guess
what I find disturbing about actors is
what I find disturbing about life is
that we all need to act sometimes we
just call it being polite oh we're all
acting acting all day acting no one pays
us for it we don't get paid we just do
it to fit in people like hey great to
meet you Tim great to me yeah
[Applause]
is it that tactic cuz you can't be
honest you can't be like I could do
without you Tim you'd be an [ __ ] fake
laughing that's another necessary type
of acting we all do and I get it
sometimes somebody tells a bad joke you
can't just be like a robot person
just like uh-huh uh-huh yes I've
assessed the content of your musing 2 nd
Matt humorless Oh small wonder we're
humans
and today you're playing the part of a
human who thinks her dentist is
hilarious
let's take it again i I do fake laughs
sometimes I don't want to but it's a
necessary part of adult life like I was
getting a drink with a girl I used to
know in college you know we used to
throw the fridge around throughout the
cool way I don't know if you've ever
been having a drink with someone you
used to know in college someone they
used to tossed mm-hmm somebody they you
just you know as a strictly frizz tossin
relationship and you see her 15 years
later and you're like 10 minutes into
the conversation you're just like oh no
whatever this was it was frizz tossing
whatever this was it's not there anymore
conversationally we can't toss the frizz
but you're stuck you can't just be like
sometimes I want to be like good boy you
can't
good boy wouldn't that be great I'm done
just walk out of the conversation you
have to stay and I could tell she was
trying to be funny she wasn't being
funny but I could tell just by her
cadence she was trying to be funny
because she'd be like
[Music]
and then she'd pause and that's how I
knew how that was a joke and I got a
laugh but it wasn't funny but I'll be
like I do my fake laugh I'm not good at
it why cuz I'm a human I'm like the
Meryl Streep of polite acting I'll do it
I know the scene I've memorized my lines
ha ha ha roll credits see you again
never and I'd like to say right up here
I realize I'm making fun of myself with
this whole thing making fun of actors
making a lot of performers I'm a
stand-up that's as bad as it gets
there's a whole world up here but I'm so
much of a narcissist I have to play all
of the characters I come up here and act
like I'm just thinking of things things
that I wrote alone in a room talking to
myself I write sketches - that's nuts
alone with a computer just going and
then this guy I imagine comes in and
there's another guy I imagine in a
coffee shop that I imagine somebody
likes a cigarette he says this he exits
that's a control freak
exit gym then we hear Jethro Tull as the
credits roll lunatic
I can't criticize actors what I'm doing
right now this monologue alone I was at
the dentist I played a robot I even
played an actor that's not normal
behavior like what's up with actors
pretending to be other people
what do you mean peope you just
pretended to be a guy asking about
actors pretending to be other people
so here's my boy thank God for the Arts
if we didn't have goons like me didn't
have the arts I just be off on a cabin
somewhere writing my manifesto
performing it for my audience of stuffed
animals does anyone need more
invisibility there's a 2 T minimum no
one to tell my creative thoughts to I'll
just be a lunatic but because of the
arts I get to come up here and be
celebrated for my dysfunction coming out
applauded for all the weird things I've
imagined and this is the best part if it
doesn't work out we've rigged it I can
just come over here and hit the applause
button
[Applause]
[Music]